Dennis Scott one of the great shooters
in NBA history is on the program Dennis
good morning how are you good morning
who gave you that nickname 3d all Porter
back down Orlando was the first game I
had three seasons I made three threes in
three minutes
my first preseason game and it goes 3:18
I look over at my suit oh wait a minute
like that it's great how would you be in
today's game where the great emphasis on
three-pointers it would be crazy then
because I remember going to Georgia Tech
in the first couple of days in practice
Bobby Crimmins like hey I know you can
shoot the three but really want to use
your size in the first situation
transition blue those meals it's got my
name's Craig Neal passes the ball to me
on the wing I let us live from the hash
mark it goes in and goes criminals oh no
no oh good I can make this Shackleton
and the rest yeah I like in your shot
you and Dell curry steps dad we're kind
of similar I always felt that it was
just great form it wasn't necessarily a
jump shot as much as it was just pure
form
did you see similarities with you and
Dell curry yes I think bill Curry's
release was quicker than mine I always
tell people that they'll courage one of
the quickest releases I've ever seen I
both in barley in there but I think what
I'll always see another guy like Glen
Rice I had a conversation with him today
about you know us playing today's game -
what the way the three-point shooters
shot has been able to be used so freely
but I think with me Dan would call
people on guard because I was shoot with
so much range I think that's what I
would fit in today because we always
talk about so much spacing on the floor
again that's how I could help today's
games okay
you can't take the shot but you got to
pick somebody game seven you are down by
two and you got a three to win it all
time who's taken two three four yeah
well can't go wrong with that I tell
people if you're going to teach your kid
you know your son or daughter to shoot
yeah
wouldn't be bad to start with with
ray-ray I think that might be the the
purest looking jump shot I ever saw
no it he has one of those pure shots I
thought Alek uses in there I would be
here on those picture perfect form so
it's a lot of guys would kind of forget
about Dan you know that's gonna watch
the game for a long time but it's good
for guys like me that now of the games
coming back European able to knock down
a wide open jump shot you can find
yourself in basketballs no way alright
you need to pick which bandwagon you're
gonna be on the rest of the playoffs
down if you're either on the Sixers
bandwagon or the pelicans this morning I
think I think at the end of the day I'm
well I have to say Philadelphia there's
all about the process we've been waiting
so long you know when Wilkinson is live
up to all the height willing be playing
and stay unselfish the way he played the
other night in Miami was incredible I
mean their bench togetherness the way
they share the basketball I think I have
to go with the fishes you know watching
the Pelican that's the biggest surprise
so far I'm not surprised Indiana's
playing Cleveland tough not surprised at
all I'm really surprised the pelicans
are up 300 on Portland how about you
that's a great point Dan because Drew
holiday is the key yeah he's the guy
were like wait a minute is this the guy
that got that 128 million a few years
ago and everyone walked at it now all
those people are quiet because now
arguably he's first team second team All
Defense he will get some of most the
most improved player because now he's
healthy like he talks about fancy games
we already know that rhinos remind us
how good Rondo was that playoff game
ever against Chicago before you focus
and so we're not shocked at that it's
all about through holiday
talking to Dennis Scott former NBA
gunner and lady that's not fair to call
you a gunner right yeah you you want it
you can be a gunner and it's a good
thing all right you were there in
Orlando Shaq's rookie year is that right
yeah okay give me a young Shaq story a
young story would
on the basketball court people have to
remember Jackie still love to run the
floor
check the alley Egyptian and block shots
when she I got to LA that's when he
became that prolific scorer as we and to
know Shaq is the biggest prankster that
you would ever know biggest friend who
you ever know so only small sriracha
real quick
may he rest in peace Brooks Thompson was
it was a rookie coming in right after
Shaq and Shaq would you know kind of
take some flex awesome icy hot and then
he would put it in his socks or the next
thing you know butch just run down of
course it yeah my feet are all fine did
he would take all the shoe and smell it
and then he was smelled I actually hide
it with those crazy not the jacket it
did Shaq run around naked and give
people hugs I know he did it later in
his career but that was always the rumor
Dennis shoes and socks first which he
kind of stole from me that he'd walk
around walking after a fire they ready
to play the young the young Shaq was
super crazy but that's always been his
personality slow him down as a retired
player doing TV and being social in
social media if that's what he is but
could you imagine Shaq with social media
Dennis he was really entertaining but
imagine Shaq with being able to tweet
and oh my goodness we were talking to
some people down in Orlando the
marketing department and just
remembering those first three years and
with the things that Shaq brought to us
there's no way that we well we might
have got in trouble we might not a god
so he said did you ever get yelled at by
Jordan or bird bird was the only one
that really kind of in his soft spoken
way when we talked them talk about guys
talking trash yeah hey look good to see
you ain't it cause career I'm gonna
catch the ball I'm a pump face you're
gonna reach for it you'll get sound to
tweet she's gonna have a seat Lord the
whole day and he catches the
pump fakes I know for that reason fast I
come down court Scott Skiles picks me
the ball I shoot a three in your face
Larry legend yes yes I'm sorry he
catches the ball again catch it
my dumb cell reaches for it in three
tweet go have a seat
I see second quarter but Jordan didn't
do that he didn't give me grief now
Jordan Jordan because I never really got
him enjoy the wedding really a trash
talker unless you really woke him up and
I think that was the park he's playing
against them and having Shaq having
penny have it dick Amazon have a good
team you squat there and playing Leave
leave Jordan alone I try to tell people
who didn't see penny hardaway what penny
could have been you know right I mean I
I just think he was one of those rare
rare talents and we never got to see the
full potential there how great do you
think Penny Hardaway could have been
always tell people special because when
you have freak-of-nature athletic
ability that's what separates you on one
level and then when you throw that
intellect in the IQ for the game that's
what takes you over the hill and that's
what made penny so special after the
injury that could he knew the game so
well he was such a great passer you
always made people around him better but
to your question though he went through
things and practiced and until your
listeners the first couple years Brian
here would call timeout because he
didn't believe what he saw he was over
to the coaches yeah I know what could
have been it's a shame they never got a
championship there but you had all the
pieces all the pieces in place he's a
Dennis Scott NBA on TNT analyst Dennis a
great to talk to you again love to have
you back and safe travels coming up for
the playoffs
thanks for having me also want to say
I'm super happy for the people in
Memphis that they hire it's penny
hardaway at the head coach and I think
the big thing is coming forth right
Thank You Dennis for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]